as stocks continue to climb investors
are putting more of their money in cash
this chart looks at how much cash
investors have and money market accounts
in the past three years the total has
climbed by one trillion dollars to three
point four trillion the highest level in
about a decade
cash is sometimes viewed as a safe but
boring investment but lately it's
looking a lot shinier than it has in a
while I'm not just two investors
analysts say if you park your cash in
the right account it can earn higher
returns without taking on more risk just
kind of the holy grail of investing
we'll explain when investors talk about
cash they mean funds that you can
quickly and easily spend or turn into
physical money it's all about liquidity
cash accounts let you withdraw funds in
a flash if you need to say fix your roof
or pay a medical expense there are a few
types of cash including currencies
deposit accounts and money market funds
each is a little different the cashius
type of cash is currency the stuff from
trees according to the Fed about 1.8
trillion in US currency circulates
through the economy through banks
businesses wallets sock drawers as an
investment though there are downsides
there's no return on cash that's stored
in a sock drawer for example an
inflation even really low inflation will
eat away at the value it's also kind of
risky if you have a lot of currency
you're probably going to want to buy a
safe now there's a lot more money in
deposit accounts let's look at savings
accounts alone cash and savings accounts
at commercial banks tops eight trillion
dollars according to the Federal Reserve
savings picked up around 2009 right
after the market crashed and battered
investment portfolios and over the past
decade savings has outpaced GDP growth
even as interest rates dropped one
analyst said that low interest rates
actually helped drive up savings
accounts the idea is that people had
less incentive to move their money from
savings to other and
Smith's the returns on some government
bonds for example were not much higher
than the savings against right now the
average return on savings accounts under
$100,000 is about point zero nine
percent but if you look around you can
do better savings accounts at some
online banks will yield you more some
around 2% now that return is more
aligned with money market funds which is
our next cash investment like we said at
the beginning there's a lot more money
and money market funds lately these
accounts are not insured by the FDIC
like savings accounts are but they hold
high rated short-term securities that
tend to hold steady in value also unlike
many savings accounts money market funds
often require minimum deposits they also
charge management fees and limit the
number of transactions you can make each
month but over the past few years
returns have grown here they are since
2009 after years near zero in 2015
rates on money market funds started
rising along with the feds interest rate
increases
they then dropped a little when the
central bank reduced rates a little
earlier this year but returns are still
higher than you'll get at your average
savings account some analysts say that
the surge and money market account
balances shows that investors are
feeling cautious they may have concerns
about the broader economy the trade war
with China and just mixed economic data
have sparked bouts of volatility in the
markets and that's pushed investors for
it's safer assets but others say all the
cash on the sidelines indicates good
health
it shows investors are not overly
excited about stocks and that they'll
have money to invest when prices drop
one thing that is clear is that a stocks
and bonds keep rising investors are
looking at cash again seriously for the
first time since the financial crisis
you might even say cash is back